hi i'm jenny and today i'm going to
discuss
app sheet automation the latest addition
to google cloud's no code offerings
this powerful capability helps anyone
quickly
and easily automate manual tasks and
reclaim the most valuable resource we
have
our time let's get started
[Music]
we lose an estimated 20 of each week to
work that could
and should be automated this is time
that could be spent on high
impact projects or ideas but is lost to
manual
tedious tasks organizations need custom
solutions to help with this
and they need them now the demand for
developers to build these solutions
however far outweighs the supply leaving
those without development knowledge or
experience to drive the solution
creation process this means that
organizations need to empower their
workforce
with a no code platform that contains
the intelligence necessary
to assist in the development process
while adhering to governance
requirements
google cloud's app sheet allows
organizations of all types and sizes to
do just that
with the ease of no code and the power
of ai
the platform's intelligence helps
auto-construct actions
based on a user's intent to implement
automations quickly
and easily app sheet automation
is an extension of appsheet's platform
to offer new
integrated workflow automation
capabilities that allow you to automate
common business processes
and document based workflows it includes
new components like bots
events tasks and processes that were
developed with modularity
and reuse in mind the modularity takes
away additional steps
and allows people like you and me to
enlist the assistance of bots that
simplify the creation of workflows
and processes these bots help automate
tedious
tasks while keeping a human in the loop
while there are numerous possibilities
to how automation can shift the burden
there are several components where
automation is a rich capability
that can help improve efficiency with
document ai
modularity external eventing and more
for now we're going to provide a
walkthrough of how quickly you can add
intelligent automations
let's get started under the automation
tab in your editor is where you'll find
your bots
bots work with your connected data
source in this case
we're using salesforce bots consisting
of events and processes can be created
or modified with a few
clicks of a button changes made are
reflected in real time in the app editor
so you always know what your automation
consists of
various data sources such as salesforce
and sheets are also supported
ensuring that you can access the data
you need
have a unique use case easily create
unique bots to trigger any number of
powerful automations to help remove
manual tasks
invoice processing for example used to
be
tedious with automation you can leverage
intelligent document processing to
extract information
and notify someone this action has been
completed
simply incorporate this into your bot
and app sheet will help with the rest
whether you're leveraging no code for
custom applications or time-saving
automations
the possibilities with app sheet are
endless
ready to change how you work get started
today by clicking the link in the
description below
you